now to an update on the Civil
investigation into the Trump
organization's business practices by the
New York attorney general CBS News has
obtained video excerpts of former
president Donald Trump's deposition in
that investigation the footage shows the
former president repeatedly invoking the
Fifth Amendment and declining to answer
questions about his or his company's
finances our Ed O'Keefe has that story
I declined to answer the question when
former president Donald Trump sat for a
deposition last August he told New York
attorney general Leticia James that he
would be invoking his right against
self-incrimination anyone in my position
not taking the Fifth Amendment would be
a fool an absolute fool and he did so
more than 400 times over nearly four
hours same answer same answer same
answer Trump who's running for the White
House once again is facing multiple
federal and state investigations the
lawsuit filed last year by James accuses
the former president three of his five
children and their company of a
long-running scheme to inflate the value
of their properties something
investigators asked Trump about
evaluations containing this document
reflect false misleading valuation
statements is that correct
same answer he would almost certainly in
any other setting and we've seen it gone
hysterical former Federal prosecutor
Harry Littman says Trump took the advice
of his lawyers to remain disciplined the
stakes are high he couldn't beat Trump
it's a really Vivid demonstration of the
justice system catching up with him and
making him abandon his normal Playbook
but in Trump's deposition which took
place just two days after the FBI had
searched his Mar-A-Lago home he was
allowed to make a statement and used it
to lash out at James we cannot permit a
renegade and out of control prosecutor
to use this investigation as a means of
advancing her political career
there's civil cases set to go to trial
in October setting up an unprecedented
legal and political situation for the
former president who of course is
running again and the various legal
issues facing Trump plus those separate
legal issues facing President Biden over
the handling of classified documents are
just the latest reminders Gail that
we've never seen anything quite like
this before
I know how many times do we have to say
that phrase when we're talking about
former president Donald Trump on many
things and speaking of the former
president he's getting some new
competition in the race for the
presidency I hear an announcement came
from
NH who is that at okay
Gail that's a clue South Carolina
Republicans familiar with the plans tell
CBS news that former South Carolina
governor and U.N Ambassador Nikki Haley
is set to announce her presidential run
in mid-February she would be the first
Republican presidential candidate to
join The Fray since former president
Trump did so last year game on
all right here we go thank you Ed always
good to see you